kochi
it was a name that sounded so sweet so
seductive god meet the family everybody
this is patricia and this is my family
they had it all
style
power who wouldn't care for that
first of all um lady gaga you're now two
of my favorite films of all time i don't
know how you are two for two but it's
incredible i'm going to start with you
and i know
that you had an incredible journey to
finding patrizia
and watching your performance was more
than a performance to me it was
transformative like you took me on a
journey that i lost where i was you were
mesmerizing so i want to know about
finding patrizia from the bigger moments
because she's such a big
larger-than-life character
down to the father-son house of gucci
those little moments that were so
nuanced that the internet loved but
that's just the tip of the iceberg
well um gosh that's that's a very big
question
i'd like to start by saying part of the
way i believe you find your character is
the camaraderie with the cast and i'm
very lucky to have an incredible cast
and everybody here was so giving and i
ultimately believe that when you show up
on set no matter how much work you've
done you have to be able to talk and
listen to each other so that you can
respond i mean
father son and house of gucci was
something that we did on the spot i mean
so much of that scene we made up and
finding patrizia was something that was
i made it a sort of life mission for
myself i became fascinated with being a
sort of journalist about it and there
was so much written about her so many
people said such bad things about her
and i wanted to create something that
was a real woman
i wanted to find what the trigger points
were in her life that uh
added up to this murder
and uh what happens to somebody that's
born
you know just like we all are into the
world and and what mattered to her you
know i i think one of my favorite things
about watching this film is not only is
every performance i think special but
she's kind of in the same place at the
end of the movie that she is at the
beginning because i thought to myself
when i watched it why did she even try
why did she even try to matter because
there was so much going on around her
that she that she couldn't possibly
transgress so
i read everything except for the book
house of gucci which i stayed away from
because i didn't want it to position my
thinking too much
and i spent a lot of time with ridley
with adam talking about the script
and i
work on a lot of personification every
single person that i worked with there
was somebody in my life i could relate
it to
and it just it also helps when you are
working with great people that you can
have those conversations with and listen
um
i
i i don't know what patricia was like
before she killed mauricio but i do know
what she was like after and i did my
best to figure out
what it would take to push a woman over
the edge to make such a big mistake i
believe it was a mistake that she made
that leads me to adam this relationship
between the two of you
there's such a huge scope to this film
and it spans decades and the way that
this relationship
starts in one place and ends in another
can you talk about
how you two found those moments and
those beats over the course of the film
and was it shot in succession uh sean
out of order we had two weeks of
rehearsal before we started so that was
really helpful to kind of map have an
idea but then then when we were playing
it i feel like we didn't really or at
least
from my perspective think of it as a
whole pieces i feel like we kind of
had a general sense of where it was
going so then we would just uh
play the scenes as they were and how it
kind of charted was was more up to
ridley it's incredible um
for you because i feel like you started
out in one place and you ended up in a
different place you say you ended up in
the same place that you started do you
feel that about your character or do you
feel like that's one of the things that
we talked about in rehearsal of uh
he kind of in a way starts the most
mature even though he starts at a place
that is uh
most immature he's very wise about the
pitfalls of uh being seduced by wealth
because it was a
part of his environment from birth so
he's aware of
all these speeches that are made to
seduce someone new but then even he when
he's put in a position of power can't
help but also be seduced by something
that he knows
uh
is dangerous so that that's something
that we talked about in rehearsal and as
we were shooting it of seduction and uh
uh and how how powerful wealth
and power can be and regardless if you
can intellectualize it to know you know
it's hard to make those decisions when
you're in the you know in the lineup
jared i'm i feel like
next to the dictionary definition of
transformation they're going to have
your photos soon and your name because
your transformations from film to film
are becoming stuff of legends
talk to me a little bit obviously there
was the five and a half hours of
prosthetics involved in makeup but for
you underneath it all
balancing that comedic beautifully
comedic performance with those almost
heartbreaking sensitivities that he had
how did you find him and find that
transformation
you go on a journey
you become a journalist
a detective of sorts and you know you
probably do far too much work
but you never know
sometimes the smallest thing can help
trigger
your imagination and
it's funny at some at one point i went
to see paulo's grave
and uh
it took a drive through the italian you
know countryside and
of course it was in the middle of covid
so it was kind of haunting and empty
um and it was really powerful to see
that this was a a real person this was
someone who lived and breathed and
walked the earth and
i i quite fell in love with the idea of
this character the impression that i had
of someone who
really struggled to
bring his creative dreams to life
wow beautiful performance mr al pacino
yes i'm going to go there and i'm going
to draw a parallel to the godfather this
is like an epic family drama what is it
about family and felonies
that seduced you into wanting to play
aldo who is your namesake in a sense
family and felony family and felonies
[Laughter]
and did you have any drawbacks like
flashbacks being in italy filming and
what is it that seduces you to play this
type of a role
well uh the uh
the director
wrigley scott and then such a great cast
i i and there they are in in italy and
i'm
here in the pandemic
or
um the vestiges of it
and i i i've been here for a while and i
can get away and go somewhere like that
little did i know that rome was on
lockdown so but it's i still would have
went no matter what because this project
this script
was exciting and wonderful opportunities
so
so i thought you know
i'll just go give it a shot like
you i rarely do that actually i i
usually uh
worry over texts and
wonder about it but this i just went
with the glow i thought i was going to
be in a
relatively comfortable place there with
these people so i went
and i actually
interestingly enough i i didn't think of
the godfather at all and you remind me
of it and i think that's a good analysis
it's also too i i just didn't
the script changed
and i was here and someone was
they were sending me changes of the text
and every change and i had nothing to do
with it
made the script better so i thought
you know somebody is in charge there
knows what
what they're doing because it really
connected so then i i went out with a
good feeling positive feeling yeah
and naturally later on like i think it
was about a month ago i realized what it
was
in the character that i was playing i
wish i would have thought of it while i
was playing it but it it you know
sometimes i don't think as much i just
i'm so used to rehearsing
because i come from the theater and and
and we
people don't rehearse as much anymore
and
so
i didn't have rehearsals so these things
come out when you're working on
something but anyway i just realized
that
i think aldo my character
wanted people
to like him and and all but enjoyed
thinking that he was smarter than
everybody
i like that
and i wonder if that was conveyed or not
but that that i said gee i wish i would
have thought of that when i was doing it
in italy
but i think that's
that's what i i i wound up uh
deciding
maybe a little late but still at all
it's well if it makes any difference i
wanted him as my uncle i want him as my
real life uncle selma i'll end with you
you have a beautiful relationship
between you and lady gaga and this and
there's a wonderful scene in a spa in a
mud bath and i'm wondering just
logistically how that looked on set was
it a girl's bonding moment or was it not
i know you've talked about lady gaga's
performance as saying it was genius but
tell me about that moment
absolutely the bonding moment that
we were so tired
it looks so beautiful and delicious i've
never had a bath mod bath before which
shocks her
how do you get to be your age and not
have a
something like this but when we went in
we didn't rehearse that because then
we're
all dirty and wash and go back in when
we went in
this one goes in like cleopatra like
nothing
you know she knows how to handle her mod
she keeps talking we do the thing
she goes in perfect gorgeous me
for some strange reason i start floating
like at this great balloon you know i
can't get my ass to hit the ground
i'm going like this and my lines
underneath ridley is not cutting he's
enjoying the the clumps
and uh she didn't in the scene provides
us to help me because
also my boobs are kind of like freaking
out of the mood i'm trying to like go in
like this so i started flipping but the
hair it was so disgraceful and a
disaster but i kept saying the lines
and then of course
i had lady gaga teach me how to sing
in the mud
which is just
just
sit your ass down and don't move the
more you move the more you're gonna
float
and so
we tried it again
but that was that scene was so fun to
shoot because it's so funny there's an
intimacy that is perceived in that
moment that they're totally alone
they're talking about how you know the
muricio can't run the business and she's
you know i was sitting there i'm like
really trying to focus on this one
candle that was at the end and there's
you know 50 men standing around you
we're trying to have a close-up but not
really when uh sam was like moving all
over the place and i just was staring at
this candle
hypnotized at what was what would what
could she possibly be thinking in this
moment where she says
well i can't say because i don't want to
give it away but it's an important
moment for super important moment yeah
time to clown around and she was
laughing and then she was making fun of
me that i was so serious and but this is
the camaraderie of two
actors and i i have so much respect for
salma and i learned so much from her and
you know the first time i ever spoke to
her she said to me
the
the
when you say supporting actress it means
something she said i'm here to support
you in your performance i never forgot
it she called me a couple weeks before
we started and it was so so kind and i
loved working with you but you know what
in our relationship pina was not
somebody sophisticated she knew how to
navigate that and pina really looked up
to patricia and pini pina wouldn't know
how to get into the the mod
and of course it would be patricia who
teaches her how to descend like le patra
and so every moment it was so funny
because it always worked it always went
back to the relationship between these
two women we were playing with
and it was such a delicious relationship
poochie
is what i say is
this is not a woman's game
remember
that to borrow another phrase from
another one of your films reversal of
fortune indeed i mean this story is so
fascinating and rodolfo for you being
the great thespian that you are must
have been there's must have been so much
for you to mine with this character
including the fact that he was an actor
did you watch any of his films was he a
good actor and he was a terrible actor
he was a terrible actor i did watch
yeah i watched some of his work filmed
you can you can find it if you research
enough and uh but he knew he wasn't a
very good actor he married a very good
actress
a german
um who he adored and he sort of gave up
and then went into the family firm and
let her get on with it and when she died
he
he really lived his life remembering her
i mean we come to him a couple of times
in the movie where he's he's
editing a film together of all his work
just so that he can watch her on the
screen it's the nearest he can get to
and now she's dead
and the man i think who
enjoyed the paycheck of gucci but wasn't
real was very conservative didn't really
wanted to change as a company he was
happy with how things were
um
which brought him into conflict with his
brother who had huge plans to build
moles on top of mount fuji and that sort
of thing
and
a a very controlling father as many
mediterranean fathers are
um
who uh wanted you know who who
[Music]
was very concerned that
that anyone else might get hold of the
the gucci honey pot
yeah
i i wanted to ask you i mean you have so
many epic scenes uh the performances
yours included are astounding in this
movie but you have a scene with jared
leto's character you have a scene with
lady gaga and adam driver where you can
cut them down like you're the man that
they almost fear you couldn't cut them
down with either a line or a look where
do you put your energy as an actor
to sort of
embody that kind of a character and and
filming with other
those other great actors
i don't know you just get inside the
head of the character and and
uh you know they get in the side of the
head to their characters and
lady gaga who is a you know a massive
star much bigger than i am nevertheless
she is playing
a woman who is trying to um
to impress
my character um
so
but but
that's what we do as actors we get
inside other people's heads we become
other people uh it's not
that hard but it's what we do the last
time you worked with ridley was in 2005
is it like riding a bike do you guys
have a rhythm that you sort of jump back
into or did it feel very different this
time from the last time
um well of course it's a smaller film
the kingdom of heaven sort of huge you
know
great epic
um this is more domestic although ridley
makes it feel pretty epic at times
uh he's 15 years older
um
i think he's a little sweeter than he
was then but he's equally quick which is
what i love he's a very quick filmmaker
he doesn't hang about
he he knows what he wants he gets it on
multiple cameras and then we can all go
home at a reasonable hour you are
wearing a scarf and there is a scene
about
the flora scarf that your character that
rodolfo actually designed for grace
kelly in the film was that actually an
archive piece that you used in that
scene or was that
was it the actual scarf i think it was
the actual yeah well i mean i i'm sure
they made more than one
um
but uh it was one of them yeah
but it's you my nephew i have been a
gucci all my life
it is an empire
you can help the family which is not
exciting and everybody knows it at least
it's my name sweetie
our name
sweetie
first of all is this true
that giannina you said to ridley for
many years you have to make this movie
you have to make this movie why was it
so important to you to make this movie
why how did you know why are you so
passionate about it and then ridley i
know you're a man of the written word
it's really the script usually they gets
you but what was the catalyst what was
that visceral what was the moment you
had that visceral reaction when you're
like we're gonna make this movie finally
two questions so the first question
i'll answer the first question is when i
read the book i read the house of gucci
by sarah forden
um i fell in love with with the story it
was so entertaining and it had passion
it had love sex murder
everything fun and fashion of course
which i
love and so
if
i just felt i want to i want to make
this movie i brought it to rid
he loved it as well
and
there started the journey looking for
the writer to to put the story on paper
and that's where the 20 years passed wow
20. we never got the story quite right
it
we didn't have at the time ridley's
availability and i really wanted to make
it with ridley he was attached three
times to this particular project
left me came back left me came back and
i finally got in
with the this new script and uh
it's been a a joy for me working with
him
this is one of the greatest casts i
think ever assembled and the level of
commitment and they took me on a journey
that i forgot i was watching a movie i
was immersed in a world that i didn't
want to leave at the end of so first of
all was it did you contact lady gaga
after you saw a star is born why was she
the right person finally for this role
and then you've never worked with al
pacino before how is that possible he
just told me he did the movie because of
you
and then jared that performance was so
unexpected um did you know he was going
to take it in that direction when you
had your initial meetings
well you know
everything's an unknown quantity and
every island is floating in my job so
you've got to be encouraged to step onto
the ice flow and so you have to make a
decision a certain point i'm looking
at the
you know
the the choice of actresses that that
then let's say a year and a half ago um
and it just made all the sense in the
world that stefania would be lady gaga
not only because of her talent and
because of star wars born but she's the
right size she's a show stopper she's
got everything that you could describe
patricia as so i think she just fitted
the bill and i never thought any more
about anybody else and she's italian and
[ __ ] yeah yes
what was your second question
jared and al and sort of piecing
together the rest of the cast
well
i've never worked with before so i look
for every opportunity
for al to to work with and i can't put
alan a suit of armor that's not gonna
work so i'm just waiting for the moment
i said okay this is kind of
a
an italian story
and it can't be a subtitle movie because
sometimes movies are kind of limited in
their choice of audiences so this is a
big movie
so al was automatically on top of the
list as the man
who played was the two godfathers and
has this wonderful
cadence where without speaking italian
he feels italian
very much so good very good point um
how integral to the story was it for you
the current house of gucci gave you the
keys to the kingdom they opened up their
archives to you
what did that look like when they opened
those doors did
visually what did it look like and and
how many choices did you have there i
have to admit i didn't go but we sent
jonty yates there with my
costume designer i worked with the since
gladiator actually and wow so we sent it
down to the gucci household the wardrobe
of the gucci
in melania
yeah in milan and uh janina kind of
opened that door because she had seen
them before she'd met some of the
gucci's 20 years ago
yeah wow
and we are friends you know we we were
lucky enough to be friends with francois
and salma who also facilitated uh
the permission to be able to see to to
go to these archives and use actual
clothes from the archives in in in one
of the scenes in in the film
where you see sophia loren walk out all
that stuff is real well and that i came
from the fashion world before i was in
hollywood and i remember that tom ford
show i watched it 100 times online the
fact the attention to detail the fact
that the amber valletta was the first
model that walked out i was like you
cast the perfect person so maybe you
could talk a little bit about
how did you create this world because
ridley you're so known for creating
these huge epic movies this has an epic
feel to it this epic family drama but
there is so much detail to it
um just a little bit about creating the
world of gucci
um i have to put it down to over the
years
i gradually
gather or even collect a great team
and so i can move so fast
and so detailed because my team helped
enormously and they're all there for a
very good reason
um
and so it's based on trust and then they
will look at things they will print i'll
make the choices they'll say what do you
want this to give me 50 choices i got
i'm still going to make the choice and
but it is to do with
i gather talented people around me that
helps you to move quickly including the
person next to you so this is a store
family this is a story about marriage
and about family
how do you as a working you know these
this family works together and it all
falls apart how do you two make it work
what is your advice
first and foremost we're so different
than mauricio and patricia yes i was
never intending it
was not comparing i'm latin he's brit
and but it it really it
we we get along exceptionally well
because we are the total opposites as
people and
and we respect each other and i think
that's super important when you work i
mean what happened with mauricio
patricia's patricia didn't respect
mauricio's opinion so that started that
at that break
we respect each other's opinion i
respect his opinion more than he
respects mine let's say the truth but he
is the master what can i say
it's very true and for you sir having
two back-to-back movies i mean the last
duel i don't i know with covid maybe the
release date but really you're giving us
a gift in 2021 we have two back-to-back
movies i also really loved that movie so
why did you make that choice to sort of
do two movies
together like that gladiator was
2 000.
and since gladia
i made 19 movies so that's the speed i
work
one movie a year in general
it's unbelievable that's normal that's
quite normal
it probably kind of got in the way a bit
but we wouldn't we kind of stepped
around it we we danced very
cautiously and cleverly around it
because
again a great team have a coveted
little organization within each film and
each film's got a unit of like
600 personnel so this every day you're
saying why do you wearing math if you
see it one more time without a match
you're off the case and you miss will go
home so we ran it like that people we
had no incidents on two big movies
what is the moment because there was a
couple there was many moments in the in
the film where there was the cast was
just extraordinary so but were you
watching from behind the scenes and
watching it like for example al's
character there's a scene where his son
betrays him instead of saying something
awful to him he hugs him and and i
wondered if that was an actor's choice
and just what was the moment maybe for
each of you that really no i said
i think it's my line actually
it's al system
my son's a fool but he's my fool an
idiot
my friend's an idiot and he's not but
he's might and so when
he the son paolo admits that he sold his
piece
which is completely
absolutely puts al out of everything
kills him
and al has his
marvelous histrionic
fit of rage
and at the end of it he has to forgive
him so i think that that's one of the
most beautiful moments where he says
you're an idiot but you're my idiot
you